now former new york city mayor rudy
gianni just learned that lesson the hard
way
yesterday when federal agents raided his
home and took his files
by our count rudy giuliani is at least
the third
attorney to have his personal
communications with former president
donald trump seized by the justice
department
sends a theme here rudy giuliani joins
us
to tell us what happened mr mayor thanks
so much for coming on
now if you'd been reading the twitter
feed of the lincoln project the
democratic hacks who
got joe biden elected you would have
known that federal agents were about to
raid your home
they knew before you did but apparently
you weren't tell us what happened
yesterday
well about six o'clock in the morning
there was a big bang bang bang on the
door
and outside were seven seven fbi agents
with a warrant
uh for um electronics
and i looked at the warrant and i said
you know this is extraordinary because
i've offered to give these
to the government and talk it over with
government for two years
i don't know why they have to do this
the agent seemed
somewhat apologetic i might say they
were very very professional and very
gentlemanly
the only time they got perturbed is at
the end of the surge
when they had taken about i'd say seven
or eight electronic items of mine which
is what they took
and and two of someone else's i
they weren't taking the three hard
drives which of course are electronic
devices they
just mimic the the computer i said well
don't you want these
and they said what are they i said those
are hunter biden's hard drives
and they said no no no no no i said are
you sure you don't want that i mean
the warrant required them to take it and
they said no
and i one last time i said don't you
think you should take it to comp
and they said no now
hunter biden's hard drives fall within
the scope of the subpoena the subpoena
required them to take all electronics
but they decided to leave that behind
and they also
were completely content to rely on my
word
that these were hunter biden's hard
drives i mean they could have been
donald trump's they could have been
vladimir putin's
they could have been anybody's but they
relied on me
the man who had to be raided in the
morning
because well i'm going to destroy the
evidence i've known about this for two
years uh tucker
i could have destroyed the evidence
years a year i didn't destroy the
evidence because the
evidence is exculpatory it proves that
the president and i and
all of us are innocent they're the ones
who are committing it's like it's like
projection they're committing the crimes
yep that well well they managed to
interject to say
it's i think literally projections so
from what we have read in the
press the department of justice wants to
know whether you violated
farah the foreign agents registration
act in representing foreign nationals
ukrainians for pay you didn't register
they're saying that may have been a
crime we know for a fact that hunter
biden did that he didn't register under
pharah
he represented ukrainians he probably
made a lot more than you did he also
represented chinese nationals
lobbying his dad and he has not been
charged with a fair violation am i
missing something here
yeah you're missing uh you know equal
administration of justice which is what
we don't have anymore
the reality is the hard drive contains
somewhere
between a dozen or more violations of
pharah that are spelled out uh
completely
failure to register uh the fact is it
also spells out as we now know
a clear violation of the gun act the the
the application is a straight out fraud
he says i'm not an addict
we have a picture of him five days
before smoking a
crack pipe behind the wheel of a car and
then saying under oath that he's not an
addict
and it's the left that gets all
perturbed about
people who are mentally unstable having
guns well he was unstable
he's been he unfortunately and
tragically i i feel sorry for that part
of hunter biden i think his
father exploited him but the reality is
he's still a danger to the public if
he's driving an automobile or holding a
gun
but they don't care about that no they
come according to my apartment
when i when i'm willing to talk to them
civilly myself
and uh second i can tell you i never
ever
represented a foreign national i in fact
i
have in my contracts a refusal to do it
because
from the time i got out of being mayor i
didn't want to lobby never did it to
bush never did it obama
never did it with trump and i can prove
it just give me an opportunity
but they always instead they had a
breakdown i would say breakdown but
smash on my doors uh in a frightening
way
lucky i don't get frightened very easily
i handled them very professionally and
they handled me very professionally
i want to make that point also hunter i
am a lawyer
who has prosecuted a lot more serious
cases
that have been prosecuted in the u.s
attorney's office since i left
and the reality is that that warrant is
completely
illegal the only way you can get a
search warrant is if you can show
that there's some evidence that the
person is going to destroy the evidence
or is going to or is going to run away
with the evidence well i've had it for
two years and i haven't destroyed it
and they also got it from the icloud
so there was no there was no
justification
for that warrant it is an illegal
unconstitutional
war uh one of many that this department
of injustice
tragically has done and it breaks my
heart because i belong to the
justice department and i think i had a
record that's a hell of a lot better
than theirs
joe biden said he didn't know the
lincoln project knew
the guys who covered up child
molestation but joe biden says
he didn't know that this raid was coming
do you take that
at face value
maybe he doesn't remember i'm not sure
if he can retain anything for more than
about
you know the time it takes to read it
but in any event who cares if he knew or
not
and the reality is how the lincoln
project knowing means
that they have a serious leak in a very
important investigation
we have been warning of that for two
years my lawyer bob costello has written
to them four times to plug up the leaks
they've done nothing to do that so
let me interrupt you i just i should
have done this at the outset i just want
to make absolutely certain
that we understand our viewers
understand what it is the justice
department says they're investigating
we've read it's a
fair violation is there something else
what have they said to you about
what they're looking into they haven't
said anything
they won't explain to me what they're
looking into for two years uh we've
called them five six occasions
said tell us what you're investigating
we'll come in and address it no just
come in and talk to us tell us about
your whole life
because that's ridiculous and so i have
to go
i have to go as a lawyer on the search
warrant the search warrant
is proportively based on one
single failure to file for representing
a ukrainian national or
official that i never represented
i have never represented a ukrainian
national or official before the united
states
government i've declined it several
times i've had contracts in
countries like ukraine in the contract
is a clause that says
i will not engage in lobbying or
foreign representation i don't do it
because i felt it would be too
compromising here i am in the middle of
representing the president of the united
states
on a charge that i believe he was
innocent of i had great passion about
that if you're a lawyer
and you're representing an innocent man
there's no greater burden you can have
and my soul concentration and i am so
offended by the things they've said
about me
my soul concentration from the beginning
here tucker was to find evidence that
would prove what i knew
that he was innocent of russian
collusion and that he was innocent of
doing anything improper
he did exactly what a president should
do with the president of ukraine
he asked him to investigate right a vice
president
who violated our wars over and over
again
30 years of the biden crime family
violating our laws
that is what is on the hard drive that
they have censored
and that's why they want to put me in
jail one of the great ironies is
the democratic party is hysterical on
the subject of russia
in part because they've taken so much
money from ukraine which of course fears
russia and has for
for an awful long time they're being
paid to hate russia but
let me just ask you so now they've taken
your phone they've taken they've got all
your texts they've got all your digital
communications
so unless you've been in mass 12 hours a
day for the last five years like is
there anybody
who could no it's a sincere question i'm
not i mean is there anybody
i know if the justice department was out
for you and they've got every text
you've ever sent
and every email that they couldn't find
something to charge you with do you
think this is going to
remain a fairer investigation or could
it get much bigger
quickly well i think it should get much
bigger i think they should be
investigated for blatantly violating
my constitutional rights the president's
constitutional rights
in the middle of the impeachment
defense they invaded without telling me
my icloud they took documents
that are privileged and then they you
know how to really decided
what they could read and not read so the
prosecutors
the justice department spied on me
and that is if that is not taken
seriously
if that doesn't result in there being
sanctioned the case being dismissed
and it's stopping this is no longer
uh a free we might as well be in you
know east berlin before the war fell
this is this is tactics only known in a
dictatorship
where you you seized a lawyer's records
right in the middle of his
representation of his client
uh i mean you should be prosecuted and
just barred for that
you shouldn't be prosecuting somebody
else i agree i agree with that they're
agreeing with that
they're a disgrace to a great department
that i served honorably and well it's
shocking
i hope you'll come back i have a feeling
we're going to be hearing a lot about i
will
story former mayor rudy giuliani thank
you